hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my speedy video so Willa Holland
finally getting called up to the majors
gonna get to have some fun in season 4
there was always a lot of question as to
what her superhero name was gonna be and
it wasn't always certain that she was
going to be a superhero
Thea queen is actually an original
creation of the show
there is no Thea queen in the comics
because there's such a strong foundation
for Oliver Queen story in the comics the
green arrow has been around for a long
time it presented some interesting
issues for her character most notably
what's her role in the narrative if
she's not an action hero she's not a
villain and she's not part of the inner
circle like she's not on classic team
arrow which is you know Diggle Felicity
and Oliver that is why she's like one of
the most underserved characters for the
first two seasons Marc Guggenheim was
actually he was really honest about how
hard it was to write for her character
just because it's like you know you have
all these things going on with the
mirakuru saga
how does Thea fit into it Merlyn was
basically the back door to that making
her Merlin's daughter in the comics
there been two really big characters to
be called speedy the first was Roy
Harper who obviously you know big
character on the show the second being
Mia Dearden obviously me Deardon doesn't
exist on the show but you have to
consider that Thea's full name is thea
dearden queen so that's how you get to
Thea speedy Queen the show has not
always been super consistent with which
character it calls speedy but I think
it's just been true to the comics
because Roy Harper has been speedy in
the comics I think that they let Oliver
call him speedy on the show just as a
reference to that thankfully Roy Harper
has had several aliases in the comics so
it wasn't that big a deal for them to
pick another one I know you might be
asking - why wasn't one of them Roy or
Thea called red arrow because that that
seemed like the final stage of them
being a superhero
it's like speedy is the nickname you
give to someone who's just starting out
then Arsenal just like a little bit more
hardcore then you graduate to red arrow
the reason I think the show went there
is because it's too similar to Oliver's
name because he's called the arrow they
would have also been called the arrow
they weren't doing green or red yet
because Oliver's not ready to be green
arrow yet so would have undercut
Oliver's journey to give one of the
other characters like the full comic
book name it's the same with the canary
in the Black Canary the way they mess
with the names it's like you get the
half name when you're still on the road
to becoming the superhero
then when you the superhero you get the
full name Thea is obviously just
starting out so her name might change in
a couple seasons too but I'm actually
kind of hoping that she stays speedy
just because it feels so appropriate for
her so what about Mia Dearden is back
story in the comics obviously like I
said very different from Thea Queens
story just because there are two
different characters because she started
out in the comics in 2001 she was
created by Kevin Smith
I think her first issue was green arrow
number two that's volume three like a
lot of female comic book heroes she has
a somewhat problematic origin story Mia
Dearden was abused by her father then
take it in by a pimp became a prostitute
and then became one of the notable
hiv-positive superheroes and DC Comics
clearly that's just like a little too
topical for the CW there enough sexual
crimes against women you know we don't
need to turn all of them into
prostitutes to show that they've
overcome struggle that's one of the
reasons why they probably gave Thea the
drug storyline in season one although
that felt kind of half-hearted like a
rich kid developing a drug habit to
rebel against their parents feels a
little cliche at this point it feels
like Judd Winick who at the time had
taken over the title wanted like an
hiv-positive character so as she became
speedy finally she was like one of the
big hiv-positive DC heroes in the
context of the comics Oliver finds her
rescues her for prostitution and
rehabilitates her by training her how to
protect herself so she eventually
becomes his ward develops a relationship
with all of her son Connor Hawke and
just continues to petition Oliver to
become his new sidekick although he
keeps denying her eventually he lets her
join the team officially that's when she
takes the name speedy that was an issue
number 45 when she took the name the
really fun thing is is that Roy Harper
came in and gave Mia all of his old gear
that he used when he used to be speedy
so her primary weapon became the bow and
arrow she eventually got tied up in this
in this big Red Hood saga where the the
Red Hood was trying to teach everyone
the consequences of taking on sidekicks
she was part of the big bruja when
Oliver Mary Black Canary although it
turned out that it was actually everyman
which is kind of funny you remember he
was actually on the flash eventually she
ended up changing her costume just just
to differentiate herself from Oliver who
you know obviously wore green and Roy
who had become red arrow at that time on
the show obviously we know Thea is going
to be wearing Roy's
old costume that just you know been
slightly modified it's just that Willa
Holland the actress is way smaller than
Colton so obviously they did shrink the
costume down just a little bit if
anything's gonna change about her
costume in season four it's just gonna
be like the addition of new special gear
like it's not gonna change in any big
way so far she hasn't really shown up in
the new 52 she only appeared in the
picture you know someone was trying to
track her down who felt she was a threat
so she only appeared in someone's
picture as a piece of evidence because
convergence is happening now and it's
kind of retconning a lot of the new 52
it remains to be seen whether or not
she's going to show up again but because
we have Thea queen on the show becoming
speedy expect to see some form of that
happen in the comics but we're at the
point now where like movies and TV are
having more influence on the comics then
the comics are having on movies and TV
at least the new comics that's a little
disingenuous I mean you know movies and
TV still borrow from the comics a lot
but it's mostly from really classic
comics like you know Frank Miller era
for the most part the characters
defining trait has been you know
troubled teen who has overcome her
really really nasty past to become a
pretty good superhero but she hasn't
risen to the level of Oliver Queen or
Roy Harper yet but you have to remember
that she hasn't been around that long
and she hasn't even really been part of
the new 52 at all so the good thing
about that is that they can do whatever
they want to on the show without
stepping on a lot of the cannon I know
you know people always complain when
they change comic book stuff but you
know I think the arrow with Thea queen
here I think they'll be just fine
usually when people are talking about
the TV show Canon they're talking about
you know how does it connect to the
movies and the answer is for for all DC
stuff across the board no matter where
it airs which network it does not cross
over that's kind of a good thing for the
arrowverse because you know the flash
arrow legends of tomorrow
Supergirl kind of not connected kind of
connected kind of a bit of a gray area
because they don't have to tie in with
the movies they can really do whatever
stories they want as long as they don't
step on the toes of the movies that's
why you see arrow pulling back on the
Suicide Squad you know even though there
are lot of great characters they
developed Warner Brothers just doesn't
want the TV show stepping on the movies
because they feel like they're gonna
make so much money with this movie
really we need to talk about how much
fun will a Holland is going to have
playing super here on the show now
because of the way they've split all the
characters off
to the four winds she actually has quite
a bit to do now to basically replacing
two people inside team arrow she's
replacing Roy I mean she took his
costume and she's replacing Oliver as
the bow using member of the team
technically Diggle is going to be the
new Oliver in Starling city like the new
team leader inside team arrow here's my
big question for you guys you know now
that Thea queen is going to be out
prowling the streets as speedy what kind
of villain do you want them to give her
to defeat I feel like one of the easy
slam dunks that you can give to comic
book characters to help them progress is
give them a big villain to defeat but
they go up against a villain get their
ass handed to them have to go off gain
new skills new knowledge grow as a
character before they can come back in
defeat said villain we really don't know
what Thea's Ark is going to be in season
4 it's a little clear what Oliver's is
gonna be everyone else is still kind of
a bit of a mystery that's the funny part
about arrow you always know where the
Oliver Queen is going whether it takes
one season two three seasons he is going
to Green Arrow that's who he's becoming
I think there is a solid chance that he
could be Green Arrow in season 5 like
early season 5 whether or not he gets
there by the end of season 4 remains to
be seen but for the most part for most
of the season he's just going to be
Oliver Queen for those asking about Roy
he is coming back to guest star in
season 4 at least a couple times
probably something to do with Thea's
storyline in the city you have to
remember that Oliver left because
they're still there so they're going to
be stuck in Starling city cleaning up
crime so just a quick reminder I might
like my DC and Marvel giveaways those
will start next week just look out for
like the Marvel and DC videos I post for
details it'll be really simple I
actually just realized that I haven't
done a Roy Harper video yet I think I
think I meant to do one earlier this
year and just never got to it so that
will probably be my next arrow video be
sure to subscribe to get that he has
been around forever so we can talk about
heroin we can talk about all kinds of
stuff there's some other cool stuff this
weekend that I'm working out I'm
probably gonna do like a new daredevil
bull's eye video because he's probably
going to be in next season so it's gonna
be a lot of fun white guys wait for that
you can click here to learn all about
near master coming to flash season 2 and
guardians of the galaxy to James Gunn's
just been dropping a bunch of details
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight